[Music]
I think one of the reasons we don't feel
joy as much as we might like is because
we have a culture in which joy is judged
often as frivolous as childish as
superficial and it's interesting to
think about where this actually comes
from it has pretty deep roots in our
culture so if you look in 1810 go to
wrote in his theory of color that savage
nations uneducated people and children
typically prefer bright colors whereas
people of refinement avoid color in
their dress and try to banish color from
the objects about them and what happens
in this equation is that we're seeing
the equivalency between savage nations
so uncivil uncivilized people
primitiveness a lack of sophistication
or education and Cha and children and
those are being equated to the sort of
aesthetics the tangible manifestations
of joy and our culture and you know when
you look at the roots of this a lot of
it stems from colonialism so you had a
bunch of Europeans getting on boats
going around the world trying to conquer
other peoples and when they found these
sort of uninhibited displays of emotion
when they found festivals and dancing
and drumming and colourful dwellings and
outfits they felt a need to distance
themselves from those behaviors and so
what happened was European culture
became more and more emotionally
repressed as a result so we had to get
rid of the colour in our surroundings
because that was uncivilized we had to
you know get rid of our sort of
exuberant and playful displays and you
actually see this when in certain
colonies when settlers would arrive they
would bring their pretty raucous
festivals I mean carnival originated in
Europe and it was a pretty raucous
festival there they would bring it to
these these colonies I can trinidad and
tobago for example and then once they
got there they realized they had to stop
visibly celebrating and they started
having formal balls instead of
you know wild celebrations because that
made them seem too close to the natives
right and so joy became you know
repressed within our culture and in its
place we got this sense of you know
seriousness that this is what is valued
and and that became reflected in our
aesthetic culture as well over the past
few years the dominant aesthetic has
been a an aesthetic of minimalism and
we've been encouraged to sort of
simplify and you know strip back our
possessions and our homes and sort of
get to very simple gray beige interiors
and in a way this has been described as
a sort of reaction to all of the over
stimulation that's going on in our
devices that it sort of helps us relax
but in fact what we find is that
minimalist interiors actually can be
very stressful that when you look at our
sort of natural love of abundance and
lushness and and textures and sensation
when you actually deprive us of
sensations we go a little bit crazy and
a study I love that sort of explores
this had a bunch of people sitting in a
room and all they had to entertain
themselves was a machine that gave
electric shocks and after only a few
minutes of sitting alone in a bare
unadorned room they started giving
themselves quite painful electric shocks
rather than sit without any stimulation
so the brain seeks and crave stimulation
and when it doesn't have that it will
sort of seek it out even in ways that
maybe aren't so adaptive a real-world
example where you can see this craving
for abundance sort of overwhelming the
the modernist desire for minimalism
happened in the plant city of Brasilia
so the city was planned out it was you
know designed as a truly modern city
with sort of uniform blocks of buildings
that all looked alike and were very
simple and and modern and orderly in
their design and what happened as people
began to move into these buildings was
that they started to miss their old
cramped abundant way of
and they started to build new suburbs on
the out on the outskirts of Brasilia and
they started to bring back their markets
and their kiosks and all of the things
that made life feel more rich and
abundant back into the city early on in
my city of joy I learned about a an
artist named Arakawa and a poet named
Madeline khun's who believed that the
dull gray boxes that we often live in in
the modern world were actually killing
us and so they set out to create a set
of apartments that they believed would
reverse aging and they called this the
reversible destiny lofts and the basic
theory is that you know our bodies are
sort of lulled our senses are lulled
into a kind of stupor by living in these
buildings that have sort of flat floors
and neutral surfaces and that we need to
sort of shake up our senses more often
and so they created this these
apartments they have sloping floors they
feel like they have these like goose
bumps over their surface that almost
look like dimples on the skin of a giant
that's sort of the way that I describe
them and when you when you walk through
this apartment you find that you know
you have to kind of hold on to the edges
to make sure you don't fall over so it's
constantly testing your balance
fortunately instead of having regular
furniture they're just poles everywhere
to help you sort of navigate your way
around the place and all of the rooms
are a little bit different than
traditional rooms so instead of having
you know just normal rectangular shaped
rooms they have a sphere is one of the
rooms there's a cylinder the bathroom is
a cylinder and it's sort of lying on its
side so you have to scramble over this
floor to get to the bathroom and
everything is painted in dozens of
different colors so this is a little
much for everyday life but it's a really
interesting experience in having your
senses tested and what I found is that
came back out into the world I was a
little bit worried that I would find
that everything else looked kind of dull
by comparison but in fact it sort of
fires up your senses and wakes them all
back up again you come back out into the
world almost more attuned to your
surroundings than when you left
[Music]
you